pregnant Kylie Jenner and Khloe
Kardashian joke about having so many
babies the famous sisters promoted their
makeup collaboration the Kylie cosmetics
in love with Coco collection in a
YouTube video released on Tuesday doing
this collection with Kylie was really
fun and I don't think we expected to do
together yeah you are really easy to
work with and I feel like we just 5 and
they seemingly poked fun at their
reported dual pregnancies a source tells
et Khloe is expecting her first child
with boyfriend Tristan Thompson we've
also learned that kylie is pregnant with
her first child too with her rapper beau
Travis Scott
however neither has publicly confirmed
to the baby news their older sister Kim
Kardashian however has confirmed that
she is currently expecting her third
child via surrogate what happens every
time I say guess what we're happy to
save you for now Khloe and Kylie are
keeping their lips sealed and talking
about their business ventures instead I
really respect that this is Kylie's
business and she built this business so
I think it's an honor to be a part of it
ét caught up with their momager Kris
Jenner on Tuesday and she couldn't help
but gush over Kylie and her booming
cosmetics business which did 420 million
in sales in just 18 months I think she's
really I think equipped to handle
whatever comes her way I'm so proud of
that kid she's a good good girl with a
big heart